où j'enregistre vidéo on est passé par
là
c'est une question de temps je pense
e
hélas à l'heure où je vous parle c'est
ce soir c'est peut-être ma dernière nuit
cet appart et je glissais beaucoup
d'émotion parce que c'est tellement
triste
franchement c'est tellement triste roi
mais des fois une fois l'amour suffit
pas
on
[Musique]
c'est une vidéo un petit peu
particulière là parce que je sais pas
quand est-ce qu'elle va sortir mais je
sais pas j'avais besoin d'eux j'avais
besoin de parler
je crois que je suis en train de vivre
les semaines les plus difficiles de ma
vie ont recommencé
bon en gros ça commence par une
séparation on vivait ensemble et donc là
moi je suis parti pour retrouver un
appartement mais j'ai pas trouvé tout de
suite donc je vais un peu de soul hoc
ans ou lock et je galère à trouver un
appartement parce que même si j'ai
l'argent j'ai pas le dossier c'est une
profession je suis indépendant voilà les
gens ils n'aiment pas ce à quoi donc
c'est compliqué et en trois semaines
changez dû faire à bouffer une fois on
voit mais reste partout c'était que là
c'est dégueulasse les poubelles
j'ai la flemme de les sortir je n'arrive
à rien en fait j'ai envie de rien
tous les matins je me réveille je me dis
ok vas-y aujourd'hui je vais tout ranger
et où j'arrive pas à quoi je sais au
fond de moi que c'est juste une phase
que ça va passer quand je vais avoir un
appartement et que quand j'aurai mon
appartement je vais recommencer à faire
mes vidéos et je porte a fait
confortablement et me reconstruire etc
mais c'est une phase de merde quoi alors
évidemment j'en veux à personne
1 je suis d'ailleurs en bons termes avec
bright monex du coup je commande des
trucs je commande du resto voilà ça
c'est le petit déj au petit déj en
mangeant ou deux et en fait je vous
montre aussi ça pour vous voyez que
voilà c'est pas toujours aussi rose
aussi je peins warriors de la
productivité jeu pas un warrior ii
habitudes se faire à manger machin tout
sa fin des fois je donne une image hyper
du parent on dira même leur propre dans
mes vidéos
ben c'est pas tout le temps comme ça je
dois aussi est-ce que je pige pas c'est
qu'il a un lit en dise on lit
souli quand je sortirai cette vidéo je
l'aurais j'espère donc mon appartement
et tout ça ce sera loin derrière moi
j'ai pour elle de sortir pendant que je
suis dedans parce que ce que j'aurais
l'impression que c'est une plainte c'est
une un appel au secours c'est ce genre
de choses et c'est pas ça c'est pas ça
un passage à vide
c'est un moment difficile
c'est comme je vous disais c'est comme
je vous disais sûrement le pire moment
difficile et ce qu'ils montrent ce
qu'ils montrent que
ma vie est quand même chouette tu vois
si le plus dur c'est ça après je pense
qu'on n'oublie pas mal de choses je
pense que j'ai vécu plus dur que savait
que j'ai oublié en fait il ya une forme
un peu de descente aux enfers quoi que
j'avais tout en fait j'avais une meuf
j'avais un appart les projets ça se
passe est trop bien et on ne peut pas
tout régler tout le temps et en plus de
ça je vais vous dire
en plus de ça il ya le contexte du
coronavirus donc là il fait de plus en
plus froid donc on peut plus trop être à
l'extérieur plus il a plu et tous et moi
je suis flipper de ouf du coronavirus
jeu plus flipper que le plus flipper de
vos potes et voilà pas du coup ça
rajoute un truc où même les potes qui
sont 6èmes soutenir etc
je ne peux que les appeler parce que je
suis pas à l'aise de les voir quoi je
suis enfermé où je m'enferme dans un
truc qui me plaît pas quoi c'est triste
j'ai l'habitude de voir sourire ans
toujours dans la volonté de notre
pétillant ou bien alors sage etc
j'ai tout ça c'est moi c'est moi et ça
aussi c'est moi et je crois qu'à une
partie de moi qui voulais vous montrer
[Musique]
ça faisait 48 heures que je te fasse
enquête chez moi et là ça me fait un
était bizarre où on fait juste
je traîne dans les rayons parce que ça
me fait plaisir de voir vu le truc quoi
ça fait très attitude de dépôt cif je
dis pas que je suis bien et on se fout
là je vois je vois légumes joie les
fruits
je vous entends qu il ya plein de choses
qui me manquent la lente reprise tout
fait depuis des semaines ça manque
en fait
ça manque la vie d'avant et on faisait à
manger tout
cela sachant prise
on va acheter des courses en effet m
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai hâte de le faire seul
oui bonjour vous appelez par rapport à
la noce qu'aux amis pour un deux pièces
voilà c'est ça oui ça serait possible de
visiter qu'un jeu fait indépendant a
fait je suis chef d'entreprise
donc j'ai la boite depuis plus de deux
ans
pour un deux pièces
dans le 18e oui il est plus disponible
ok bonne journée à revoir
[Musique]
tom tu tiens j'ai visité un appartement
hier eh ben je les ai eus mec
ah non non non pas celui-là non non je
n'ai pas envoyé en vidéo je vais pas
envoyer binger un appart je suis trop
content les amis je suis je suis hyper
content je ne reçois un appel
j'ai un appart normalement j'ai du mal à
le dire parce que j'ai peur j'ai peur
que finalement ça se passe pas mais
je crois je crois que ça y est
j'ai un appart
il a une énorme pièce à vivre ça sera la
pièce où bureau tournage de vidéos etc
tout ça et donc j'ai trop hâte qu'on l'a
qu'on la fasse un peu ensemble quoi je
voulais montrer et je vais essayer de me
projeter réfléchir à comment organiser
les trucs etc je vais essayer de vous
amener avec moi dans tout processus
ça y est la regarder ça me donne envie
de créer ça donne envie de créer des
trucs avez-vous ça me donne envie de
vous montrer des trucs je suis tellement
content d'avoir trouvé un appartement
j'avais tellement peur
ouais
[Musique]
c'est en anglais il m'a dit a dit m
it's gonna be ok m
if it's not ok it's my dinh
en
[Musique]